اهلا بكم قتل اكثر من 60 شخصا واصيب عشرات
اخرون اثر قصف صاروخي نفذته طائرات النظام
السوري الجمعه واستهدف سوقا شعبيه مكتظه
بالمتو
في مدينه حموريه بالغوطه الشرقيه في ريف
دمشق نتوقف مع هذا الخبر لنناقش في محورين
ما الذي يدفع النظام السوري لاستهداف سوق
مقتضى بالمدنيين وما حكم القانون الدولي
في مثل هذا
العمل وما هي الانعكاسات التي يمكن ان
تترتب على هذه المجزره وردود الفعل التي
يمكن ان
تثيرها
قتل اكثر من 60 مدنيا واصيب عشرات اخرون
في قصف صاروخي لطائرات النظام السوري على
مدينه حموريه في ريف دمشق وقد استهدف
القصف حسب ما نقلت مراسله الجزيره في ريف
دمشق سوقا شعبيه مكتظه بالرواد تزامن ذلك
مع تكثيف قوات النظام غاراتها على مدن
وبلدات دومه وعربين وزملكا في ريف دمشق
كذلك يا ستار تردد طيران النظام السوري في
استهداف المناطق الاهله بالمدنيين والمبرر
في نظره وقوعها في دائره سيطره المعارضه
وراء اعمده دخان هذه يختبئ مشهد السوق
العام في بلده حموريه بالغوطه الشرقيه
بريف دمشق هاتوا طفوا
المي هاتي سوق الخضار وتجمع الباعه
المتجولين استهدفوا بصواريخ موجهه من قبل
طائرات النظام السوري والناشطون يؤكدون
سقوط الع عشرات بين قتيل
وجريح سيارات الاسعاف والمشافي الميدانيه
في ارجاء الغوطه الشرقيه تكرر نداءات
الاستغاثه وتؤكد في كل مره عن عجزها عن
استقبال هذه الاعداد من
الضحايا تعكس الصور التي يبثها الناشطون
استهداف طائرات النظام لكل شيء يساعد
البشر في هذه البقعه على البقاء والصمود
والاستمرار في
الحياه معنا في هذه الحلقه
من غازي عنتاب محمد سرميني مستشار رئيس
الحكومه السوريه المؤقته من عمان اللواء
فائز الدويري الخبير في الشؤون العسكريه
والاستراتيجيه ومن بيروت الكاتب الصحفي
فيصل عبد الساتر لكن وقبل ان نبدا النقاش
مع ضيوفنا نتوقف مع السيده دياله شحاده
المحاميه السابقه في محكمه الجنايات
الدوليه معنا من بيروت السيده ديال شحاده
ما التوصيف لعملك الذي تابعناه معا في هذا
التقرير وجرى في
حموريه نعم وفقا لاتفاقيات جنيف الاربعه
وايضا وفقا لنظام روما الاساسي الذي انشا
المحكمه الجنائيه الدوليه ليس هناك شك في
ان ما جرى اليوم في سوريا وتحديدا في
الغوطه هو جريمه ضد الانسانيه وايضا جريمه
حرب الاستهداف المباشر لمكان ماهول
بالسكان في وضح النهار ومن دون ان يكون
هناك اي لبس في ان هذا الموقع ليس محطه
عسكريه هو جريمه حرب وهو جريمه ضد
الانسانيه
ايضا في هذه الحاله يعني كيف يمكن التاكد
تماما من انها
كذلك بالمعنى يعني بالمعنى القانوني
اقصد نعم بالمعنى القانوني عناصر الجريمه
ضد الانسانيه هو الاستهداف الواسع المقصود
لمجموعه من السكان المدنيين سواء لبيوتهم
او لشخصهم واجسادهم وهذا كان جليا في
الصور التي نقلتها عيون العدسه وايضا
عدسات هواتف الاشخاص الموجودين في هذه
المنطقه وايضا يمكن توصيف هذه الجريمه
بجريمه حرب فيما لو اعتبر انها تاتي في
سياق نزاع مسلح وان هناك مسلحين موجودين
في هذه المنطقه في الحالتين هذه جريمه حرب
يعاقب عليها القانون الدولي من دون شك
يعني في بعض في بعض الحالات يقال دائما او
احيانا على الاقل بان هناك مسلحين في تلك
المناطق وربما دخلوا في اشتباك مع قوات
النظام هل يشكل ه اي نوع من التبرير لشيء
من هذا
القبيل بتاتا وجود المسلحين ينقل توصيف
الجريمه من جريمه ضد الانسانيه الى جريمه
حرب ولكنه لا يرفع المسؤوليه باي شكل عن
الشخص او الاشخاص الذين اعطوا الاوامر
لاستهداف السكان المدنيين اما اذا كنا
نتكلم عن شخص او اكثر او بضعه اشخاص سقطوا
في جريمه او في عفوا في استهداف لقاعده
عسكريه بشكل هامشي فيمكن هنا الجدال حول
الموضوع اما استهداف سوق ماهول بالسكان
وبالتجارب المدنيين فهناك فهنا لا يمكن
باي شكل رفع المسؤوليه الجنائيه عن
الاشخاص الذين قاموا بهذا الفعل يعني لرفع
الموضوع هذا ل محافل دوليه كيف يمكن اتخاذ
خطوات في هذا
الاتجاه هناك اكثر من طريقه من اجل محاسبه
الاشخاص الذين ارتكبوا هذه الجريمه للاسف
فيما يتعلق بالمحكمه الجنائيه الدوليه
هناك اختصاص محدد حصرا في نظام روما
الاساسي فاما ان تكون سوريا قد صادقت
كحكومة الى المحكمه الجنائيه الدوليه لكي
تنظر فيها وهناك ايضا طريقه اخرى من اجل
محاسبه المسؤولين وهي
باالتفاح وليس دوليه ذات اختصاص عالمي
كالمحامين تنظر في الجرائم الدوليه وفي
جرائم التعذيب وفي جرائم القتل وبعضها
موجود في اوروبا ولكن ايضا اختصاصه محصور
في اراضي هذه الدول اي ان المشتبه فيهم
يجب ان يزوروا هذه الدول وان يكون هناك
مذكرات توقيف صادره بحقهم قبل زيارتهم
شكرا جزيلا لك سيده ديال شحاده المحامي
السابقه في محكمه الجنايات الدوليه كنتت
معنا من بيروت شكرا لكل هذه التوضيحات
اللواء فايز الدويري من الناحيه العسكريه
البحته كيف يمكن ان نفهم ما
جرى ايه اولا دعني اقول في البدايه ان هذه
المجزره في هذا اليوم هي ليست غريبه عن
المسار العام لنهج النظام خلال الاربع
سنوات الماضيه اتحاد التنسيقيات اصدر
بالامس تقريرا اي وضح فيه انه ارتكب خلال
عام 2014 512 مجزره منها 221 مجزره
استخدمت نتجت نتيجه استخدام البراميل
المتفجره و 143 مجزره نتيجه استخدام
الطيران الحربي للقنابل الموجهه سواء كانت
فراغيه او عنقوديه علينا ان نتذكر كذلك ان
الغوطه محاصره منذ اكثر من عامين وبالتالي
النظام يسعى جاهدا ل تضييق الخناق على من
تبقى في هذه المنطقه ويعاقب البيئه
الاجتماعيه ويدمر ما تبقى من البنيه
التحتيه وبالتالي النظام عندما يستخدم
البراميل المتفجره البراميل المتفجره هي
تعمل عن نتيجه الاسقاط الحر والجاذبيه
وبفعل الجاذبيه الارضيه وبالتالي لا يوجد
هدف محدد لها وتعتبر اسلحه توجه تعتبر
اسلحه تتوجه الى مناطق وليس الى اهداف
وبالتالي هذ هذا البرميل المتفجر يمكن ان
يسقط في السوق الشعبي او على مسجد او على
كنيس او او كنيسه او غير ذلك انما الاساس
فيها انه عدم احترام ادميه الانسان
وامكانيه الهروب من التبعيات لان سوريا لم
توقع لغايه الان على على ميثاق روما اذا
هي عمليه دمويه وكما ذكرت ضيفتك قبل قليل
هي تندرج تحت جرائم ضد الانسانيه والاباده
الجماعيه ولكن اي هدف هنا اسال السيد فيصل
عبد الستار عبد الساتر عفوا اي هدف يمكن
ان يكون ل قوات النظام من وراء عمليه من
هذا
القبيل يعني اولا يعني ما دمنا نتحدث الان
عن جرائم ضد الانسانيه هل هذه الجماعات
المسلحه بوجودها في مثل هذه المناطق هي
يعني تشتغل يعني مع الانسانيه ام انها ضد
الانسانيه هل عندما تمنع المصالحات في هذه
المناطق وتطلق النار على المتظاهرين الذين
ضاقوا زرعا بوجودهم هل ه هذا ليس ضد
الانسانيه فلماذا لا تتحرك كل وسائل
الاعلام بما جرى في بيت سحم منذ يومين او
بما جرى في حموريه ايضا عندما خرج المئات
من المواطنين وامن لهم الجيش السوري
انسحابا من هذه المنطقه وقدم لهم الطعام
والماوى ام اننا فقط نسلط الضوء عندما
يكون هناك عملا عسكريا معينا ليحدث هذه
الضجه انا لا اريد ان ادافع بالمطلق لكن
اتحدث عن معايير يعني ما دامت الضيفه
الكريمه الاستاذه ديالا شحادي مباشره
اصدرت احكامها دون ان يكون هناك اي تحقيق
فهي تعتمد على صور بالموبايل حسب ما يعني
ادعت واللواء فايز الدويري الان يتحدث
بلغه عسكريه بحته عن ان الصواريخ او
البراميل المتفجره تنزل من اعلى الى
الاسفل على طريقه الجاذبيه وكان الجيش
العربي السوري ليس له درايه بتوجيه
الصواريخ او عندما يريد ان يقصف اهداف
محدده هذا بالمبدا ثانيا عندما نتحدث ما
الذي يريده الجيش العربي السوري الان
عندما يقصف مثل هذه المناطق الجيش العربي
السوري يقصف عندما يكون هناك نيران تخرج
من هذه المنطقه ولعله هؤلاء يعني هذه
الجماعات المسلحه تتخذ من بعض المناطق
السكنيه ايضا حصنا حصينا لها وهذا حصل في
كثير من القرى والبلدات سواء في دير الزور
او في حما او في كث كثير من المناطق لا
ننسى ما حدث في مورك مثلا على سبيل المثال
لا ننسى انهم افتعلوا الكثير من المجازر
ثم احتموا بالكثير من القرى والبلدات
استاذ محمد اذا ك ن ولكن اسمح لي سيد عبد
الساتر يعني يعني قبل ان اعطي المجال سيد
محمد سرميني المنطق الذي تتحدث به انت
الان اسمح لي واعذرني على التشبيه كثيرا
ما تعتمده كثيرا ما تع تعتمده حتى قوات
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي في غزه وغير غزه
لتبرير سقوط ناس يعني فيه نوع من
الاستهانه بالمدنيين ومحاوله ايجاد
اعذار لا اسمح لي استاذ محمد انا لا اوافق
عليه بالمقارنه ابدا اولا كل ضحيه تسقط
مدنيه هي خساره لسوريا سواء كان هؤلاء في
بيئه يسيطر عليها المسلحون او في بيئه
امنه يسيطر عليها الجيش العربي السوري كل
مدني يسقط ضحيه هو خساره لسوريا الوطن
بالمعنى العام للكلمه لان هؤلاء ربما لا
ذنب لهم بما يحدث لكن عمليا لا نريد ان
نحمل الامور فوق طاقتها اليوم سقط ضحايا
في مز الجبل مز الجبل في اخر احياء دمشق
من الناحيه الغربيه هل ايضا صواريخ الجيش
العربي السوري هي التي اسقطت هذه الضحايا
ام ان هناك قصفا من المناطق في مناطق
الغوطه الشرقيه تتعرض له احياء دمشق كل
يوم من جوبر ومن دوما ومن حرستا باتجاه
المناطق الامنه في دمشق
التيش حياتها اليوميه نعم هذه الاسئله
التي طرحتها الان لنح للسيد محمد سرميني
حتى يوضح بعض
النقاط يعني اسمح لي في البدايه ان اتوجه
بالعزاء الى اهالينا ولشهداء الذين يبدوا
في في هذا في هذا المشهد لم يعد لهم عز
وخصوصا ان عدد الضحايا وعدد الشهداء
المستمر والمتزايد منذ اربع سنوات اصبح
مجرد ارقام للاسف الشديد هذا هذه المجازر
كما ذكر سياده العميد انها اصبحت يعني
بعشرات وبم تحدث في سوريا نتيجه ان النظام
منذ المجزره الاولى ومنذ المجزره الاولى
الي جرت في الخالديه منذ اكثر من ثلاث
سنوات المجتمع الدولي لم يتحرك ولم يقدم
ساكنا ثم مجزره المجزره الكبرى التي حصلت
في الغوطه من خلال استخدام الكيماوي والذي
وقف المجتمع الدولي عاجزا دون ان يتحرك
ودون ان يقدم اي شيء في الحقيقه ما ما
ذكرته ضيفتك الكريمه فيما يتعلق في
اتفاقيه جنيف وحقوق الانسان وان ما جرى هو
فعلا جريمه جريمه حرب وجريمه ضد الانسانيه
لكنها هذه سلسله من الجرائم ضد الانسانيه
و وجرائم الحرب الذي ما زال المجتمع
الدولي يقف ان يشاهد فيها حتى اليوم اننا
لم نسمع اي تعليق دولي او اي تعليق رسمي
اتجاه هذه المجازر هذه المجازر اليوم لم
تقم فقط في حموريه وفي في دوما انما ايضا
منذ كان اليوم في الحوله عندما خرج
المصلين من المسجد تم استهدافهم من من
خلال ما يسمى او ما يسميه ضيفك في بيروت
انه طيران الجيش العربي السوري هذا الجيش
هو توصيف دقيق لما ذكرته فيما يتعلق في
التشبيه انه نعم هو شبيه ل القوات ال
العدو الصهيوني هم يقتلون المدنيين
والابرياء ثم يخرج من يتكلم باسمهم ليبرر
قتل هؤلاء الحقيقه ان ماود ذكره في ان
المجتمع الدولي للاسف الشديد وعلى راسهم
الامم المتحده باتوا شركاء في قتل
المدنيين والابرياء وخصوصا عندما لم
يقوموا باي تحرك نعم نعم اعلم تماما ان
هناك فيتو صيني وروسي دائما يواجه اي قرار
اممي لكن كما ذكر سابقا هذا المجتمع
الدولي وهذه المؤسسه التي الامميه وهي
منظ الامم المتحده لم تعد قادره على الحسم
ولم تقد قادره على اتخاذ اي اجراء من شانه
حمايه المدنيين وتحقيق العداله والحفاظ
على حقوق الانسان نعم انت انت انت انت هنا
سيد انت هنا سيد سميني بعد بعد اذنك انت
هنا
تنقلنا بشكل واضح لمحور الثاني نريد ان
نعرف بعد الفاصل ما هي الانعكاسات التي
يمكن ان تنجر من وراء ما جرى في حموريه
وخاصه ما الذي يمكن ان يجري عمليا على
الصعيد الدولي لايقاف هذا النوع من
الممارسات لنا عوده بعد فاصل قصير نرجو ان
تبقوا
معنا
اهلا بكم من جديد مازلتم معنا في هذه
الحلقه من ما وراء الخبر والتي نتناول
فيها دوافع وابعاد مجدره حموريه بريف دمشق
والتداعيات التي يمكن ان تترتب عليها لواء
فايز الدويري
ربما يصبح مملا ان ان نسال ما الذي يمكن
ان يترتب على شيء من هذا القبيل برايك على
صعيد المحافل
الدوليه دعني في في البدايه اوضح نقطه
لانه ضيفك من بيروت طرح تساؤلا علينا ان
نعود الى بدايه استخدام البراميل المتفجره
كانت يتم اشعالها يدويا وتسقط يدويا من
الطائرات العموديه ومن ثم تم تطويرها
واصبحت تحمل على الطائرات الحربيه وتسقط
من الطائرات ولكنها سلاح غير موجه يضاف
الى ذلك انا ذكرت في المقاربه الاولى ان
143 مجزره ارتكبت نتيجه استخدام الق ذائف
الموجهه وهي قنابل فراغيه مما يعني ان
استخدامها كان عن سابق اصرار وتصميم الان
اجيبك على سؤالك اخي اذا عدنا الى المجازر
خلال الاربع سنوات هي تعدت اكثر من 1400
مجزره كانت اهمها مجزره الغوطه في شهر اب
من عام 2013 عندما تحرك العالم مبدئيا
باتجاه وهددت امريكا باتجاه استخدام القوه
لكن اذا عدنا فقط الى شهر تشرين الثاني
ارتكب النظام في منطقه المستودع الاصفر
شمال الرقه مجزره في خلال يوم واحد قتل
25 مدني كان منهم تقريبا
174 طفل لم يتحرك العالم يمكن ان تصدر
بيانات شجب وتنديد ولكن اصبحت قضيه الشعب
السوري المدمر هي قضيه منسيه بالنسبه
للعالم والعالم لا يتحدث الا عن تنظيم
الدوله ويتحدث عن كوباني ويتحدث عن بعض
الجزئيات في الجغرافيا السوريه بينما
الخسائر الرئيسيه التي يعان تحدث ويعاني
منها الشعب السوري هي تاتي على يد قوات
النظام عن سابق اصرار وتصميم وبالتالي انا
لا اتوقع ايه ردود تصب في صالح تخليص
الشعب السوري من هذه المجازر والايام
القادمه ستثبت ذلك ان لم اكن مخطئا يعني
اشرت الى انشغال المجتمع الدولي بقضايا
اخرى هناك ايضا نقطه ايه اخرى سيد فيصل
عبد الساتر هناك احساس او شعور عام يتم
تداوله الان في الاوساط المؤيده للنظام
السوري على ان محور الممانعه كما يسمى او
محور المقاومه هو الان في وضع جيد واستعاد
زمام المبادره
وان المحور الاخر هو المحور الضعيف
والمتراجحات
بان اشاعه انطباع من هذا القبيل يجعل
النظام السوري قادر على ان ي يضرب وهو
متاكد بان لا احد سيعاقبه ولا احد
سيلاحقه يعني اولا يعني دعني ارد على بعض
النقاط بشكل مباشر وسريع وهذا ليس له
علاقه بان محور مقاومه قوي او ضعيف او انه
يعني يتقدم او انه يتراجع نحن نعرف ان هذه
الحرب هي حرب مفتوحه منذ اربع سنوات الى
الان وهي ليست في سوريا لوحدها بل هي في
كل المنطقه تشتعل وتنطفئ بايرادات خارجيه
وب اراده دوليه الذي يتحدث الان الاستاذ
محمد سرميني ربما يظن نفسه يعني فعلا انه
نائب رئيس حكومه يعني عن اي حكومه يتحدث
حكومه ليس فيها اي شخص موجود في ارض سوريا
ثم يتحدثون عن حكومه ارجوك سيد عبد الس لا
لا تقييم لا تقييم المعارضه السوريه واداء
بالم
الشخصى الشخصي انت طرحك لهذه التساؤلات
طرحك لهذه التساؤلات وهي مشروعه تبعدنا عن
الحديث عن المجدره نريد ان نبقى في شيء
مريع من الناحيه الانسانيه انا كان سؤالي
هل تعتقد بان النظام يشعر الان انه مرتاح
طالما هو يقوم بما
يفعل بامكانه ان يستخف بالاخرين هذا هو
سؤالي لا لا المساله ليست لها علاقه
بالراحه او عدم الراحه المساله لها علاقه
باستراتيجيه متبعه من قبل الجيش العربي
السوري ربما هذا الامر يعني طالت طال امده
نوعا ما هو تامين كل الم المناطق المحيطه
بالعاصمه دمشق وتجفيف مناف منابع الارهاب
ومنابع مجموعات المسلحه في هذه المناطق
حيث يقوم على ركيزتين اثنتين الركيزه
الاولى هي اقامه المصالحات في بعض المناطق
كما حصل في يلدا وبيت سحم وغيرها من
المناطق المحيطه بالعاصمه دمشق وايضا على
ركيزه اخرى وهي الركيزه التي تتعلق
بالمواجهه العسكريه مع مثل هذه الجماعات
في الحرب ح حت حتى حتى لو كان هذا الثمن
ال الانساني بهذه
الفداحة لهذا الموضوع لنترك الامر حتى
نتبين فعلا لكن انا اقول لك اني العرب
تخيل تتخيل انه المعارضه يمكن ان تضرب سوق
شعبيه هكذا ببراميل
متفجره يعني الذي قام
بتفجير مشف الطائرات بطائرات الذي الذي قا
الذي قام بتفجير مشفى الكندي باطنان من
المتفجرات وسواه بالارض تماما وقتل المئات
من الابرياء يفعل اي اي شيء ممكن ان ت لكن
هذا القص الطيران لا من حيث المعطيات
الواقعيه هذا ما جرى في
في هذا الحادث هو بالطائرات يعني القضيه
موثقه بهذا
الشكل ما ماشي ممكن يكون ان يكون هناك
مركزا كبيرا للمجموعات المسلحه في هذه
المنطقه وممكن ان تكون الطائره قد اخطات
لكن ان تقول لي ان جيش العربي السوري
يتعمد ان يقصف مناطق امنه ومناطق مدنيه
انا استب عد هذا الامر تماما لم يحصل لو
كان هذا الامر حصل لكنت لكانت ارتاحت
سوريا منذ زمن بعيد من هذه الازمه لكن
المشكله في ان الجيش العربي السوري ربما
دفع اثمان مضاعفه نتيجه تردده في الاقتحام
في كثير من المواقف وكثير من المتى يدفع
وت وحتى لا يدفع عفوا حتى لا يدفع اثمان
اكثر من ذلك نسال في نهايه البرنامج سيد
محمد سرميني بالنسبه للمعارضه كيف لها ان
تنقل احداث من هذا القبيل الى مستوى افضل
على الساحه الدوليه لان مثل ما اشرت قبل
قليل اصبح متابعه اصبحت متابعه الشان
السوري وهذا السقوط للضحايا وكانه مساله
عاديه لا لا تحرك
ساكنا يعني لا شك ان اليوم كما ذكرت
المجتمع الدولي غير مكترث وغير مبالي لما
يجري في سوريا للاسف الشديد وهذه مشكله
كبيره لكن ما او ذكره ان هناك مطالب
حقيقيه هي التي ستق انا اسف جدا سيد
سرميني انا اسف جدا واضح واضح ان هناك خلل
في الميكروفون الذي لديك سنحاول ان نصلحه
بسرعه ونعود اليك ارجو ان يتم ذلك في اسرع
وقت سيد فايز الدويري في انتظار ان يتم
معالجه هذا الموضوع ما الذي يمكن عمليا ان
يتم الان لنقل هذه الاحداث الى درجه افضل
من الاهتمام
الدولي اولا اي ال الائتلاف لغايه الان لا
يؤدي دوره بشكل جيد في نقل الصوره
الحقيقيه عما يجري في الداخل ولا يستخدم
القنوات السياسيه والدبلوماسيه لايصال هذا
المشكله الى الى الجهات الدوليه البعد
الاخر لا يزال هناك عقم ك واضح جدا لدى
الائتلاف ولدى ال المجلس العسكري الاعلى
ورئاسه الاركان في احداث تواصل مع وسائل
الاعلام العالميه لتكون على درايه ومعرفه
بما يجري في الداخل السوري هناك قصور وهذا
القصور تتحم يتحمل الائتلاف ورئاسه
الاركان والدول الصديقه للشعب السوري في
الدقيقه الاخيره هذه سنعود الى السيد محمد
سرميني مع الاعتذار للهنا التي في الصوت
تفضل سيد
سرميني للاس للاسف نحن نعتذر للسيد سرميني
على هذا الخلل جعلنا لم لا نستمع اليه
تفضل اذا سيد فايز الدويري عمليا ما ما
الخطوه التي يمكن ان ان يقوم بها هذا
الائتلاف لتلافي هذا التقصير كما تشير يا
س س س سيدي الائتلاف لديه سفارات في بعض
الدول لديه شخصيات بارزه لها علاقات مع مع
دول مختلفه عليها ان تؤكد على البعد
الاعلامي وعليها ان تنقل الصوره الى وسائل
الاعلام العالميه ذات التاثير على على
شعوب تلك الدول ودول تلك الدول ن نعتذر
منك سيد دويري عوده اخيره للسيد سرميني
تفضل يعني كما ذكرت بالنسبه لما يتعلق في
الشان الدبلوماسي والسياسي وحتى الاعلامي
كل الجرائم التي ذكرتها سابقا واكبرها
مجدره الغوطه نقلت عبر وسائل الاعلام
الدوليه والعالميه وكانت هناك تغطيات
مباشره ايضا كذلك ك لقاءات على اعلى
المستويات ابتداء من البيت الابيض
الامريكي وانتهاء في كل دول اصدقائنا تم
شرح ما يجري من مجازر لكن كما ذكرت هناك
عقم في المجتمع الدولي لا يستطيع ان يتحرك
اتجاه اي ايجاد حل حقيقي اود ان ذكره ما
اود ذكره في الحقيقه المجتمع الدولي الي ح
سياسي اعتذر من اعتذر منك سيد سرميني مره
اخرى شكرا لك شكرا لكل ضيوفنا بهذا نصل
الى نهايه هذه الحلقه في امان
الله